Why aren't you all home
like the rest of the class.
My subject today is
parrot Cleaves as general.
I don't expect that it
will take up all our time.
So if you like when I'm through I'd
be glad to respond to any questions or
comments that you want to make
about the Peloponnesian War.
So if you're if you think of any as I'm
talking I hope you'll have a shot at it.
Near the end of his biography of Pericles
Plutarch describes his great Athenian
leader on his deathbed.
The best men of Athens and his personal
friends are gathered in his room and are
discussing the greatness of his
virtues and the power he held.
Thinking he was asleep.
They added up his achievements
and the number of his trophies.
For his general.
He had set up nine commemorating
a victory on behalf of the city.
Now we are inclined to think of Pericles
primarily as a great political leader a
brilliant orator a patron of the Arts and
Sciences the man who whose work in the
peaceful arts shaped what is often
called the Golden Age of Athens
so it's useful for us to remember that
the office to which the people elected
him almost every year for some 30 years
from which he carried on all of these
activities was that of strata Goss general
and that foremost responsibility of
Athenian generals was to lead
armies and navies into battle.
From his own time until modern times
Pericles talents as a general have been
criticized and defended in the first
year of the Peloponnesian War when his
strategy called for the
Athenians to huddle behind
the walls of their city while
the invading Peloponnesian army
ravage their lands in Attica.
Lucidity says the city was angry with
Paris police they abused him because as
their general he did not lead them out
into battle and they held him responsible
for all they were suffering
in the next year after another invasion
and destruction of their crops and farms.
And after a terrible plague had struck
the city against acidity says they blame
Pericles for persuading them to go to
war and they held him responsible for
their misfortunes.
At a lower level the poet Herr MIPS one
of the poets comic poets whose work we
don't have but occasionally we
have a quotation and here's one.
Herr members present to
one of his comedies in the
spring of 430 the second year
of the war that simply charged
Paris Cleese with cowardice.
He addresses Pericles as follows.
King of the SAT here's why don't you
ever lift a spear but instead only use
dreadful words to wage the war.
Assuming the character
of the cowardly Teles.
But if a little knife is sharpened on a
whetstone you roar as though bitten by
the fierce click on clean as you know
was his major opponent in the last years
of his life and Clinton was hawkish
and an advocate of aggressive active
fighting.
Now the title of this talk Pericles is
general is also the name of the most
vehement modern attack on Pericles.
As a general I say modern of course
I'm talking about the 19th century when
you're an ancient historian.
Things take on those proportions.
The author Dr. Julius fun fluke Hartung
was a veteran of the Franco Prussian war
and an appreciative student of what he
took to be the lessons taught by the
great military historian and
theorists theorist Clausewitz.
He believed that he had acquired some
useful knowledge of the science of war as
he put it that led him vigorously and
entirely to condemn Pericles as general
generalship in Pericles conduct
of the Peloponnesian War he says.
We see expeditions without inner unity
without the possibility of greater
results.
And I'm quoting Luke
Hartung now to avoid danger.
Pericles regularly gave
away important advantages.
Overall we find the effort to lose no
battle but nowhere to win one as much as
Pericles personal courage operated
in battle and in the assembly.
So little did he have the courage proper
to a general which boldly risks the
life of thousands at the decisive moment.
As such he belongs to those.
One may say a philosophical group which
brings everything as neatly as possible
into the system and plan.
Instead of acting openly and vigorously.
It is a fact that cleaves the chief
advocate of the anti Spartan policy never
offered a single battle
against the Spartans
at the higher level of strategy.
The critique of Pericles is no less
severe prickly is was a good minister of
war.
Who made far sighted preparations but
as General he did not know how to make
good use of the existing situation.
Again I quote He was
a great booga Meister.
This means mayor said it was not a very
friendly thing to call the great general
who led Athens. It was a great burger
Meister. In the true sense of the word.
There is the rich many sidedness of his
nature which was then by that which came
into play his superiority to
corruption everything petty and paltry.
Yet he lacked the prophet's vision and
the certain luck of the born statesman.
Above all he lacked the recklessness which
is often needed to lead what has been
what has begun to the goal.
As the leader of foreign policy he was
not comparable to a sin Mr. Cleese as a
general not even approximately to Akeem on
so that's the harshest of
the critics of Pericles.
Over the years but Pericles has been very
lucky over the years in his defenders
in antiquity.
His performance was justified
and praised by lucidity.
It was after all a contemporary general
himself and the historian of the period
whose interpretations have dominated
opinion ever since he wrote for all the
objectivity of the acidity style he
tells the story very much from Pericles
viewpoint.
For instance when he describes the
revolt against the Athenian leader in the
second year of the war and the Athenians
unsuccessful effort to make peace.
This is how he describes the aftermath
being totally at a loss as what as to
what to do.
They the Athenian people attack
Pericles and when he saw that they were
exasperated and doing everything as he
had anticipated he called an assembly
since he was still general.
He wanted to put confidence into them
and leading them away from their anger to
restore their calm and their courage.
He reports three of Pericles that is to
say Cincinnati's does reports three of
Pericles speeches at length without
reporting any of the speeches made by his
opponents on those occasions with the
result that the reader is made to see the
situation through Pericles eyes.
And finally he makes his own judgment
perfectly clear coming down firmly and
powerfully on the side of Pericles
and against all of his critics
here's what's to say that he says as
long as he led the state in peacetime he
kept to a moderate policy and kept it
safe and it was under his leadership that
Athens reached her greatest heights.
And when the war came and it appears
that he also judged its power correctly
Pericles lived for two years and six
months after the war began and after his
death his foresight about the war was
acknowledged still more for he had said
that if the Athenians stayed
on the defensive maintained
their navy and did not
try to expand their empire in wartime
thereby endangering the state.
They would win out but they acted
opposite to his advice in every way.
And when their efforts failed they
harm the state's conduct of the war.
Now in spite of his success excuses
of his successor's departure from his
strategy and the disasters that resulted
in spite of the entry of the Persian
Empire into the enemy ranks the Athenians
held out for ten years after the
disastrous Sicilian expedition and for
twenty seven years with interruption
altogether here's what you said at his
final word on this subject so more than
abundant was parrot Cleaves reasons for
his own predictions that Athens would
have won in a war against
the Peloponnesian along the
city's makes it absolutely
clear cities.
Apparently it was right in the strategy
that he had adopted and if the Athenians
had stuck to it they
would have won the war.
Plutarch accepted to sit in his judgment.
And added further defense against
the charges of cowardice and lack of
enterprise that his enemies were
launching against Pericles to Plutarch.
The actions that provoked such into
accusations instead revealed prudence
moderation and a desire to protect the
safety of Athenian soldiers in 454.
We're back now.
In the first Peloponnesian War Pericles
led a sea borne expedition into the
Corinthian Gulf.
Facilities merely reports that he defeated
the sick he only ends in battle and
ravaged the territory and besieged
the important city of anybody.
Though he failed to take it and then
sailed home obviously answering later
criticism Plutarch concludes his account
of these events by saying that Pericles
returned to Athens and now I quote him
having showed himself to be formidable to
the enemy but a safe and effective
commander to his fellow citizens for no
misfortune struck the
men on the expedition
and 437 he sailed into the black sea on
a mission of imperial consolidation that
amounted to little more
than showing the flag.
To the local barbarians an action that
was too insignificant to be even noticed
by its editors.
But Plutarch does not miss the chance
to meet the criticism that had been
directed against his hero.
On this campaign according to Plutarch
Pericles displayed the magnitude of his
forces and the fearlessness and
confident courage with which they sailed
wherever they liked and place the entire
sea under their power and 446 when B
OCA was in rebellion the
bold and ambitious general
told Mahdi's convinced the
Assembly to send him at the head of an
army to put down the uprising Plutarch
reports that Pericles tried to restrain
and to persuade him to in the Assembly
making his famous remark.
That if he would not listen to parents
please he would not go wrong in waiting
for time.
The wisest counselor
but told he didn't listen and he went.
And the result was a disaster.
The Athenians suffered many casualties.
Thomas's was kill B OCA was lost Plutarch
comment is that this is an incident
brought great fame and
goodwill to Pericles as a man
of prudence and patriotism.
Later in the same year
rebellion broke out in UBS.
And Negara revolted. Opening the road
for a Peloponnesian invasion of Attica.
Pericles on this occasion had no choice
he led an Athenian army out to meet the
invading army.
But instead of fighting
a battle he convinced the
Spartans to withdraw and then
to negotiate a peace.
In retrospect no doubt his critics accused
him of missing a chance for victory
in the field facilities
reports the Peloponnesian
withdrawal without comment or
explanation.
But Plutarch uses this action to respond
in almost poetic language to later
charges that accompany the Peloponnesian
invasion in 431 reporting that his
enemies Pericles enemies threatened and
denounced him and choruses sang mocking
songs to his shame and insulted his
generalship for its cowardice and for
abandoning everything to the enemy.
The Peloponnesian Plutarch
tells us expected the
Athenians to fight out of anger
and pride but apparently as it appeared
terrible to fight a battle against sixty
thousand Peloponnesian and
b ocean hotlines for that
was a number of those who
made the first invasion.
I'm still quoting Plutarch and to
state the city itself on the outcome he
reports Pericles calming language to
the XIV excited Athenians and 431 saying
that trees though cut
and lopped grew quickly.
But if men were destroyed it was not
easy to get them back again had he turned
off.
I'm sorry here he turned to the charges
of cowardice and lack of enterprise and
he turned them on their heads and did
so more fully in a passage that sums up
his view of Pericles generalship.
And I'll read it to
you in his generalship.
He was especially famous for his caution.
He never will.
He never willingly undertook a battle
that involved great risk or uncertainty.
Nor did he envy or emulate those who
took great risks with brilliant success.
And were admired as great generals.
He always said to his fellow citizens
that as far as it was in his power they
would live forever and be immortals.
Of the many modern scholars who have been
persuaded by this view none has argued
more forcefully in favor of Pericles
generalship than Hunt's Del Brook.
Perhaps the most renowned military
historian of his day and still a respected
figure in that field he he and
Hartung were contemporaries.
They lived in the well they did their
writing on this subject in the last
decades of the nineteenth century.
Annoyed by by the critics critiques
rather lately leveled at Pericles and
especially by Flockhart John.
He wrote a thorough defense in 1890
under the title The General's ship of
Pericles explained through the
generalship of Frederick the Great.
His main effort in that work is to
justify Pericles conduct of the war that
began in 431.
The subject of the greatest criticism
leveled at the Athenian general
Pericles strategy did not aim at defeating
the Spartans in battle but was meant
to convince them that war
against Athens was futile.
His strategic goals therefore
were entirely defensive
he told the Athenians that
if they would remain quiet
take care of their fleet.
Refrain from trying to extend their empire
in wartime and so putting their city
in danger they would prevail the Athenians
were to reject battle on land abandon
their fields and homes in the country to
Spartan devastation and retreat behind
their walls.
Meanwhile their navy would launch a series
of commando raids on the coast of the
Peloponnese.
This strategy would continue until the
frustrated enemy was prepared to make
peace.
The naval raids and landings were not
meant to do serious harm but merely to
annoy the enemy and to suggest how much
damage the Athenians could do if they
chose.
The strategy was not to exhaust the
Peloponnesian physically or materially but
psychologically
no such strategy had ever been attempted
in Greek history for no state before
the coming of the Athenian
imperial democracy.
Ever had the man the means
for trying such a strategy.
To do so was not easy for
this unprecedented strategy
was ran directly across
the grain.
As you know of Greek tradition
willingness to fight.
Bravery and steadfastness in battle became
the essential characteristics of the
free man and the citizen
Pericles strategy of passivity.
Therefore ran counter to the
teachings of the Greek tradition.
But most Athenians were farmers whose
lands and homes were outside the walls.
The prickly and strategy required them
to look on idly while their houses crops
and vines and olive trees were damaged
or entirely destroyed in the face of
these facts as well as of the power of
tradition and the cultural values of the
Greeks.
It is hard to understand even in
retrospect how Pericles could convince the
Athenians to adopt his strategy.
Tilbrook keenly aware of Athens
numerical inferiority on land.
Was Convinced of the soundness
of Pericles approach.
Here's what Del Brooke wrote.
The structure of the Peloponnesian War
obliges us to give him a position not
simply among the great statesmen but
also among the great military leaders of
world history.
It is not his war plan as such that
bestows this right on him for the fame of
the commander is gained not by word but
by deed but rather the gigantic power of
decision that accompanied it not to haul
with a half measure but to plunge in
whole heartedly and to give up completely
what had to be sacrificed the entire
attic countryside.
And in addition the strength of personal
authority that was able to make such a
decision understandable to a Democratic
National Assembly and to gain their
approval the execution of this decision
is a strategic deed that can be compared
favorably with any victory
take that critics Delle
Brook was pulling no punches.
And if you said he was a bum
I say he was the greatest
Del Brooke tries to bolster his case by
comparing Pericles with Frederick the
Great King of Prussia in the 18th century.
During the seven years war Frederick
applied Waddell Brook calls a strategy of
exhaustion instead of the strategy of
annihilation in which one army seeks out
the other to bring it to decisive
battle with the goal of destroying its
nation's ability to resist
such a strategy is sometimes adopted
by or forced upon the weaker side in a
conflict because no other
choice promises success.
In the 20th century the North Vietnamese
Communists used it with success against
the United States superior firepower
brought the Americans victory and set
battles but was not so effective in
dealing with various forms of guerrilla
warfare.
The Communists therefore usually
avoided battles throughout the war.
Continuing warfare over years without
a decisive result fed division and
discontent in America and ultimately
exhausted the American will to fight.
In the second Punic War Rome repeatedly
suffered crushing defeats in battle at
the hands of Hannibal.
The Romans therefore chose the tactics
of quinces Fabius Maximus avoiding battle
harassing the enemy with guerrilla
warfare until they grew stronger.
And he far from home and cut off from it
by sea grew weaker and was compelled to
withdraw prickliness.
Strategy however was un like
these strategies in many
ways unlike the Vietnamese
Communists and the Romans.
He never attempted a set battle on
land the Vietnamese war down America's
resolve by inflicting
casualties on their forces.
The Romans avoided battle only
sale so long as they had to.
Their ultimate aim was to defeat the
enemy in standard battles which finally
they did.
In Italy Spain and Africa Del Brook's
comparison with Frederick strategy seems
to me no less faulty the Prussian monarch
was driven to it by combat losses in
set battles fought over two years and
by the absence of any alternative he
needed to avoid battle to survive.
Only good fortune not calculated war
plans could save him Britain came to his
aid with financial assistance and then
the most incalculable of all things
happened.
The death of the row of the room sorry
the Russian empress who was a great fan
of the.
I mean who was hostile to Frederick
broke up the coalition of his enemies
allowing him to escape from the war
unbeaten she was succeeded by a tsar who
loved Frederick the Great
and there by saved his neck.
The situation confronting Pericles was
entirely different from these cases.
No helpful allies stood in the wings
and no fortunate accident came to divide
his opponents since he avoided all
fighting on land against the Spartans.
He inflicted no casualties as the
Vietnamese and the Romans did.
They and Frederick moreover aimed finally
at fighting and winning battles when
the odds were in their favor.
The core of Pericles plan however was to
avoid all land battles to show that the
Palestinians could do Athens no serious
harm and to exhaust them psychologically
to make them see reason and understand
that their efforts were futile and could
not bring them victory his plan
did not work the element of chance.
The unexpected and incalculable intervened
against Pyrrhic leaves and against
Athens in the form of the terrible plague
that ultimately killed a third of the
Athenian population.
Of course all this encourage the pull
up nations who refused to be discouraged
and continue to fight.
When Pericles died and for twenty nine
the Athenian Treasury was running dry.
His plan lay in ruins and there
was no prospect for victory.
Only when his successors turned to a more
aggressive strategy did the Athenians
level the playing field and achieve a
position allow them to hold out for twenty
seven years.
And indeed on more than one occasion
almost brought victory so it's not
surprising that Pericles strategy and
the prickly and the Peloponnesian War has
brought criticism that raises questions
about his capacity as a military leader
even from sober and friendly scholars
Garrow booze old very distinguished German
historian. Regarded his
strategy as fundamentally right.
But even he thought that it was somewhat
one sided and doctrinaire and in its
execution it was lacking in energetic
procedure and in the spirit of enterprise.
That's from a very good friend
Hermann Bentsen.
As you can see the Germans have dominated
this entire field of discussion.
Defends the plan against its critics but
concedes that the carrying out of the
offensive part of the plan appears to
modern viewers as not very energetic and
resolute.
I'll say their influence no doubt
these critics are by the knowledge that
prickly successors took some actions that
did not risk significant land battles
or numerous casualties and yet produced
important successes in the spring of
four twenty five.
The brilliant and daring
general Damascus's conceived
and executed a plan to
seize and fortify the promontory of
pylons at the south western tip of the
Peloponnese is from there the Athenians
could launch raids at will and encourage
the escape or rebellion of the Hilux
Spartans enslaved population his success.
Panic.
The Spartans who allowed several hundred
of their troops to be trapped and
captured on the island of
Spectre readjust off pylons.
The immediately proposed a peace
which the Athenians then refused
later in the same spring
the insane Athenians seized
and garrison the island of
Cicero just off the south eastern tip
of the Peloponnese and immediately began
to launch raids against the mainland.
To today's reports that the Spartans
suffered what I think of as pretty much a
nervous breakdown.
Here's the accounts facilities gift the
Spartans sent garrisons here and there
throughout the country deciding the
number of hot lights by what seemed
necessary at each place.
In other respects they were very much
on guard for fear that there would be a
revolution against the established order.
And from every direction a war rose up
around them which was swift and defied
precaution in military of affairs.
They now became more
timid than ever before
since they were involved
in a naval contest outside
their normal conceptions of
preparation for war.
And in this unaccustomed area they
fought against the Athenians to whom the
mission of an enterprise was always a
loss in respect to what they had expected
to achieve.
In other words whatever victories the
Athenians won however great they are
always disappointed because they
had expected more than that.
At the same time the misfortunes
that had struck them in such numbers
unexpectedly and in such a
short time caused great terror.
And they were afraid they Spartans were
that another calamity might again strike
them sometime like the one
on the islands victory.
For this reason they were less daring
and going into battle and they thought
that whatever they undertook would
turn out badly because they had no
self-confidence.
As a result of having little
previous experience with misfortune.
Let me just remind you of the enormous
confidence with which they entered the
war thinking that it would
be no problem at all.
All they had to do was walk into Attica
and either the Athenians would come out
to fight them as they had done the last
time and be destroyed immediately or
they would surrender rather
than see their lands destroyed.
And look where to what they had been
reduced not by apparently a strategy of
exhaustion but by the rejection of
that strategy and the effort at a more
aggressive approach.
In the light of results such as these
it is natural to ask why did the
enterprises that produced the need.
I'm sorry that the enterprises
that produced these
successes why do they need to
wait until the fifth year of the war.
Why didn't Pericles use them at once.
His failure to do so is the most weighty
of the charges brought against him and
Del Brook uses much effort
and ingenuity to defend him.
He is forced to concede however that a
more aggressive offensive effort would
have been helpful.
He believes that the attack Pericles led
against epic dowries in the second year
of the war and 430 was meant
to take and hold that city.
Quote from Del Brooke if any
such conquests had succeeded
any success in at car
Narnia any campaign of devastation.
However intensive any fortification
of a coastal spot in Massena would
disappear.
In comparison taking up the dollars
he says would have threatened the
neighboring states near the coast.
It might bring peace at once or at least
cool the ardor for war amongst parties
allies.
So why did Pericles wait and then do so
little Del Brooks answer is we do not
know.
The failure by so learned clever and
determined a scholar and by his many other
defenders to explain Pericles behavior
in this way I think is a powerful sign
that they have taken the wrong path.
Pericles did not mean to use any serious
offensive measures to wear down the
enemy's ability to fight.
His goal as I have said before was
psychological and intellectual to convince
the Spartans and their allies that
victory was impossible that the Athenians
could easily sustain the only
damage the enemy could inflict.
The ravishing of Attica and to show
that the ally to show to the allies.
I'm sorry that the
allies at the Athenians.
Forgive me to show it to them and
realize that the Athenians could do them
considerable harm if they chose Athens
carefully calculated limited offensive
efforts were meant to deliver a message
without inciting the enemy to fight and
to fight harder.
Just as the carefully calculated limited
attacks by American forces against
North Vietnam aimed at putting pressure
on the enemy without causing their
Chinese supporters to intervene that
kind of strategy calls for very delicate
action and very delicate judgment.
And of course there's no
guarantee that it will work.
The offensive part of Pericles plan
was deliberately to do little harm for
actions that were too aggressive
might anger the enemy and harden his
determination.
The goal was to depress the enemy's spirit
by showing that there was no way for
them to win to destroy their will to
fight just a little footnote here.
That's always a critical issue in any
strategy that any body adopts in a war.
Really a two fundamental goals.
And they are not always.
They do not always
produce the same strategy.
One is to make it impossible for the
enemy to fight to destroy his capacity to
fight.
If you do that you have certain victory.
The other is to destroy his will to fight.
And of course if you do that you win but
his will may not be responsive to your
approach.
If they could destroy the Spartan
will they could be expected to make an
associated piece that would return to
the status quo before the war only made
more secure by the demonstration that
it could not be overthrown by force.
And that was Pericles his aim in the war
that strategy failed as had Pericles.
Diplomatic maneuvers in the period leading
to war from four thirty three to four
thirty one when civil war and epidemics.
A remote town on the fringes of the Greek
world threatened to bring a great war
between the Peloponnesian
league and the Athenian Empire.
Perry clearly Pericles as I have argued
to you pursued a policy of restrained
limited intervention meant to deter
Kahn's Spartans important ally without
driving the Spartans and all their
Peloponnesian allies into a war against
Athens that effort also
failed and resulted in a
terrible war that Pericles had
wanted to have to avoid.
Do these great strategic failures fully
make the case for Pericles critics were
they the result of cowardice lack
of enterprise and resolution.
I think that a fair examination of
his performance throughout his life as
general suggests otherwise.
The charge of personal cowardice is
ludicrous even fluke Hartung concedes that
his personal courage operated
in battle and in the assembly.
No Athenian who led armies and navies
in many battles repeatedly setting up
trophies of victory could
have escaped condemnation.
Had he shown any sign of cowardice
nor could he have been re-elected Gen.
year after year.
If that was the picture of him
nor did he fail to demonstrate boldness
and enterprise in 446 the very survival
of Athens and her empire were threatened.
The most menacing rebellions
broke out close to home.
You'll be a mega be OCA prickly swiftly
took an army to put down the ruby in
rebellion and justice swiftly withdrew
on news of the second which opens the
door to a Peloponnesian
invasion of Attica. He arrived.
You remember too it just in time to
persuade the Spartans to withdraw.
And then he returned at once to UBS
to suppress the rebellions there.
And again when the island of
Samos launched a dangerous
rebellion back and forth
40 Pericles took personal charge acting
promptly and decisively in catching the
same year and rebels unprepared
for his swift reaction.
Taking them by surprise ultimately forcing
them to surrender by means of a naval
blockade.
These expeditions however show
that Pericles frequent caution.
Did not derive chiefly from
a temperamental tendency
or a character flaw but
from thought and calculation.
The main reason he avoided land battles
against their Spartan the Spartan and
Peloponnesian allies is
because he was certain to lose.
The numbers were decisively against him.
Yet he was more careful then were bolder
generals no poets in the Greek world
was prodigal with its citizens in battle.
And it behooves the general especially
in a democratic state to keep the
casualty lists as low as possible.
We need to remember that Athenian generals
were not only military leaders but
also politicians who needed to be
re-elected to their posts every year
no doubt Pericles sincerely took pride
in the prudence and economy of his
leadership but it could not have hurt
his political popularity when he boasted
to the Athenians.
What I've quoted before that as far
as it was in his power they would live
forever and be immortals.
Such considerations help explain
his cautious performance.
And yet there is no evidence to suggest
that he was one of those rare military
geniuses who belong in
the ranks of Hannibal.
Caesar Alexander the Great a lesser but
still worthy example in our own time
George Patton who understand the limits
of rational calculation in war and the
need boldly to seize opportunity when
it offers proclaims was what a term that
was used in the second world war.
A soldier's general as the PR forces of
Omar Bradley attached that title to him.
He was no George Patton or perhaps even
a Bernard Montgomery who seeks battle
only when the odds are
very heavily in his favor.
He lacked the flair and the boldness of
a claim on the daring and ruthlessness
that seeks victory at any cost.
Another element has been suggested to
explain the prickly in strategy Pericles
himself says one critic was rather an
admiral than a general the Athenian
Admiralty it was which framed the strategy
at the outset of the war not Pericles
the Borg Meister but proclaims the admiral
invented the strategy of exhaustion a
strategy which came near to ruining Athens
in a couple of years and could never
have won the victory. Well there
was some merit in this analysis.
The Athenians under Pericles had built
a grand strategy that was based on naval
power.
That might seem to suit a maritime empire
whose homeland was an island such as
Great Britain's or a power that dominates
a continent and is separated from
other great powers by two great
oceans like the United States Athens
geographical situation was not so
fortunate for the city was attached to the
mainland offering targets of coercion
not available to the enemies of the great
Anglo-Saxon countries.
Paris please try to cancel that
disadvantage by building the long walls
connecting the city to
its fortified harbour.
Thereby in effect turning
the city into an island.
It was an extraordinary strategy far
ahead of its time in its reliance on human
reason and technology and its rejection
of traditional ways of fighting that
cost lives and gave
the enemy an advantage.
At the same time he abandoned all ideas
of further expansion and devised a
policy aimed at preserving
peace and the status quo.
That perfectly suited Athenian interests.
Such a policy dependent for success on
an extraordinary extraordinary amount of
rationality on everyone's part.
The Athenians must be content with
what they have and abandon hopes for
extension of their power.
There were always the
Athenians who objected to that.
But while he lived Pericles had the
wisdom and the political strength to
restrain and control them.
What he could not control were the
other states and especially the enemy.
Unexpected changes and shifts in power
are the normal condition of international
history.
These changes have always taken place
because international relations are guided
only partially and spasmodic early
by rational calculations of material
advantage.
Always at work as well are
greed ambition jealousy.
Resentment anger hatred and facilities
famous triad fear honor and interest
in the world as it has been.
Therefore a state satisfied with its
situation and wishing to preserve peace
cannot rely on a reasoned export it
responds to its reason policies but must
anticipate challenges
that seem unreasonable.
The Spartans and their allies ought
to have recognized that they had no
realistic strategy to promise victory
over Pericles reliance on defense and
refusal to fight a major land battle but
resentment and anger at Athenian power
and the fear that it might ultimately on
their mind their own alliance and their
security led them to fight.
As I find it usual in human history they
were more influenced by the memory of
the Athenians failure to
fight a traditional battle
and negotiating a peace in
forty forty six then by the recognition
that the new technology in the form of
the long walls made it unnecessary for
Athens to risk such a battle in the
future
to deter a war in such circumstances
which is what Pericles was trying to do
requires some offensive threat to the
pelican nations whose menace was great and
impossible to underestimate that would
make the fear of immediate consequences
of war stronger than all
the emotions leading to war.
But Pericles had come to think of
Athens as an invulnerable island.
Since the acquisition of a fleet of vast
treasury to support it and defensible
walls for such a state to adopt
a defensive strategy is natural.
It had developed a unique and enviable
way of fighting that use these advantages
and avoided much of the
danger and unpleasantness of
ordinary warfare and allow
the Athenians to concentrate their forces
quickly and attack islands and coastal
enemies before they were prepared.
And it permitted them to strike others
without danger to their own city and
population.
Success.
And this style of warfare made it seem
the only one necessary and defeats with
great losses on land made the Athenians
reluctant to take risks by fighting on
land
offensive action in their views should
be taken as a last resort only only when
it was absolutely unavoidable.
Pericles carried this approach to its
logical conclusion by refusing to use a
land army even in defense of the homeland
much less by using it in offensive
efforts that might do
the enemy serious harm.
The enemy's passionate refusal to see
reason made what might be called the
Athenian way of warfare.
Inadequate and Pericles strategy a form
of wishful thinking that failed for a
state like Athens in 431.
Satisfied with the situation capable of
keeping the enemy at bay the temptation
to avoid the risks of
offensive action is great.
But as people often don't
notice it contains great
dangers it tends to create a
rigid way of thinking that leads men to
apply a previously successful strategy
or one supported by a general theory
to a situation in which it is not
appropriate.
But it may have other disadvantages as
well its capacity to deter potential
enemies from provoking a
war is severely limited.
Deterrence by standing behind a strong
defensive position and thereby depriving
the enemy of the chance of victory.
A suit assumes a very high degree of
rationality and some degree of imagination
on the part of the enemy Spartans invaded
attic and 430 1 They must have thought
they were risking little even if the
Athenians refused to fight even if they
persisted in that refusal for a long time.
Both of which they thought
was unlikely and unnatural.
The Spartans would still be risking
little more than time and effort.
In any case their lands and city would
be safe had the Athenians possessed the
capacity to strike where the enemy was
vulnerable and had that capacity been
obvious to everybody.
Pericles strategy of deterrence
might have been effective
once the war came.
There was no way to win without
abandoning the Athenian way of war and the
parrot clan strategy as Pericles
lay dying in the fall of 429.
His strategy was a failure after three
campaigning seasons the Peloponnesian
showed no signs of exhaustion of any kind.
On the contrary they had just lately
refused an Athenian offer of peace and
fought on with a determination to
destroy Athenian power forever.
The Athenians on the other hand had
seen their lands and homes ravaged
repeatedly their crops and
trees burnt and destroyed.
They were also suffering from the plague
which was killing great numbers of them
and destroying their moral fiber in
the anecdote that I be I quoted at the
beginning of this talk.
Plutarch speaks of Pericles response
to the praise of his military prowess.
You'll remember he expressed astonishment.
You know they thought he was sleeping
it turned out he wasn't he was hearing
what they were saying.
He expressed astonishment that they
should be praising what was the result of
good fortune as much as his own talents
and what many others had accomplished.
Instead he said they should be praising
the finest and the most important of his
claims to greatness that no Athenian
now alive has put on mourning clothes
because of me.
That assertion.
The last words of Pericles reported to
us must have astounded his audience.
Even his friends would have had to
admit that his policy had contributed at
least something to the coming of the war
and that his strategy had something to
do with the intensity of the
destruction caused by the play.
His final words show deeply how he felt
the wounds caused by the widespread
accusations hurled against him
and his stubborn refusal to admit.
That he had been wrong in any way.
He had applied his great intelligence
to his city's needs and reason told him
that he was not responsible for the
results which he must have believed to be
temporary.
He must have thought in
time his expectations would
be fulfilled if his fellow
citizens would have
the wisdom and courage.
To hold to his strategy
they would win out.
So he believed and so did his contemporary
facilities more than two millennia
later.
Clausewitz saw war through
very different eyes.
I quote him.
War.
Is more than a true chameleon.
That slightly shapes its characteristics
to the given case as a total
phenomenon.
Its dominant tendencies always make
war a paradoxical trinity composed of
primordial violence hatred and enmity
which are to be regarded as a blind
natural force of the play of chance and
probability within which the creative
spirit is free to roam and its elements
of subordination as an instrument of
policy which makes it subject to reason
alone these three tendencies are like
three different codes of law.
Deep rooted in their subject and yet
variable in their relationship to one
another.
A theory that ignores any one of them or
seeks to fix an arbitrary relationship
between them would conflict with reality
to such an extent that for this reason
alone it would be totally useless
like most generals in history and unlike
its few military geniuses Pericles saw
war as essentially a linear phenomenon
subject as Clausewitz said to reason
alone and too little in my judgment.
Did he understand its other aspects.
For that he and his people
paid a very great price.
OK.
Well we do have some time and I'd be very
glad to hear any questions or comments
and any of you would like to make.
After all we only have
a twenty seven year war.
We got 20 minutes to talk about it. No
problem. Anybody have anything to say.
Yes.
Why is.
This way writers of antiquity
works to harness that power.
Why was it in the.
That's a fairly long story but I think
the best answer I can give is the one I
gave yesterday last time when I spoke
about Cincinnati's reasons for writing the
story that he did.
He had been a supporter of Pericles
and things hadn't worked out well.
The state had gone in a direction very
different from the one that he favored
including a strategy that
was the opposite of Pericles.
The average guy in the street who was a
guy that he didn't approve of very much
thought wrongly Heath.
He believed that Pericles had been right
had been dead wrong was Pericles fault
they went to war was powerful his
fault they lost the war and facilities
associated himself I think with Pericles
and his approach to things and so he
had to make the case that he
believed the case he made.
I mean it's very important to realize that
and Plutarch coming many centuries
later like everybody who has ever spoken
about the Peloponnesian War once their
cities had written was powerfully
influenced by three cities.
I think just about everybody who's ever
considered the war has come away pretty
much with facilities
judgment of these things.
So I think that's the answer to that
somebody will handle. No
I imagine the hand yes.
The question is can I think of any modern
generals who did use Pericles approach
as a model.
I think the answer is not anybody.
Well yeah.
General McClellan
in the civil war and it was
a very analogous situation.
McClellan did not want
to fight Lee's army.
He wasn't all that crazy about
the antislavery stuff anyway.
But apart from that he didn't want to pay
the price which was a tremendous price
of fighting the Civil War.
And so he wanted to avoid battle and
pretty much Lincoln couldn't get him to
fight.
So
that was.
That's one example now this the next
the next thing I would offer you as
something to chew on at least it because
it's not identical it's only similar.
I think the the strategy undertaken by
the secretary of defense and the current
administration in launching the attacks
on Afghanistan and on Persia Persian
Iraq.
I got Greeks I got Greeks on my mind.
I have to fight Persians.
Iraq reflected an aspect of it.
They would both for reasons I don't have
to explain to you desperately eager to
reduce casualties to a minimum.
And they were desperately eager to.
Choose a an an approach that would
limit the time that the war lasted.
Because of the political situation in
the last decades in American history and
they had an advantage technologically
that seemed to make that possible.
America's fantastic advantage in
firepower and the capacity to deliver the
firepower at a distance with very little
risk to the deliverers with the notion
of doing tremendous
harm when it got there.
But you I don't know if any
of you remember any of this.
Some of you were too young to
even think about it I guess.
But originally remember what
was that phrase that they had.
What was that great strategy we were going
to use by bombing the hell out of the
Iraqis.
Shock and Awe.
It was the same thing.
Shock and all was meant to say Oh my
God this is gonna happen to us we quit.
Was what they had in mind
and they deliberately chose
not to have ground forces
that would have been capable of doing
the kinds of things that it turns out you
need to do to be successful in
these wars just like other wars.
So the end.
And when it happened that it was clear
things were not working out according to
their plan.
They stubbornly clung to that plan even
as the evidence was that it wasn't going
to work. So that would be a
candidate I'd suggest. Yes.
Yeah.
A little bit louder please.
A
Yeah.
The question is do I.
Do I think that the recent Athenian
history or the structure of the democratic
society. Democracy had anything to
do with the adoption of this plant.
Perhaps.
You're absolutely right.
There must have been a very clear and
painful memory of what happened to
Thomas's when he invaded Bosnia.
There were very very heavy
casualties there for the Athenians.
That's the only one in
which they did have a.
But they did have those and they were
unusual so that it may have persuaded
Pericles that the Athenian
people would find it hard.
But on balance I really think not.
I don't think that the Athenian
democracy was very different from the
oligarchies of the other Greek cities in
the way they thought about things they
would have much preferred to fight it out.
It was only Pericles incredible command
of the political situation that allowed
him to take the strategy that people
had what the world is this guy doing.
And they turned against it very swiftly.
So no I don't think that democracy
was especially important now.
The enemies of Pericles and the enemies
of democracy I should say the enemy of
Americans.
I mean the ancient enemies of democracy
do say that it was the Athenian
democracies way of running the war which
guaranteed disaster and they fixed on
something that comes later down the road.
The Sicilian expedition which was a
dangerous undertaking as it turned out
although these things didn't think
so at the time and they think only a
democracy could have done anything as
stupid as that and they are in that way
following precisely what lucidity says.
But if you read my account you'll see
that is another way of looking at it but
that that's what the ancient
anti-democratic view was.
Democracies are idiots they don't know
how to conduct war do anything else right.
They will bring disaster. I think
you can get disaster a lot of ways.
Julieta
and yet we know that Turkey
was only one of my generals.
So my question was Is
there any evidence that the
yet.
No.
It's very clear that so long as Pericles
was in charge everybody did what
Pericles wanted done.
Part of the reason was that we know pretty
well from the evidence that at least
a good number of the 10
generals in any one year were.
Close to Pericles so that his
political influence spread.
Very unusual thing in the
ancient world for any body.
In ancient Athens for anybody to have
that kind of a carry over effect.
But we see there's always several generals
that we know are friends of Pericles
and I think the rest of the story is
that you see the generals don't get to
decide what they do. In ancient Athens
this is the part that blows your mind
when you send an army out that Army gets
a general or more it gets an assigned
amount of money and equipment
and stuff and it gets orders.
And all of those things are decided by
the Assembly after a debate by a majority
vote.
And what I would suggest to you is
that Pericles did not lose any of those
arguments except in the one case when
they came after him and nail them and then
they put him back in office again.
So does that take care of your question.
That's a good yeah.
Heather
you probably didn't
want to have just gone.
Yeah.
The question the heart of the question
is why was apparently it wise to adopt a
strategy no matter how good a strategy
it might have been which he knew the
Athenians didn't like.
And I think the answer.
Well in the end the outcome is obvious.
No he wasn't wise but that's I think more
because the strategy was faulty not so
much because the Athenians didn't like it.
He had proven over the years and he
proved now in the most delicate of times
that essentially he could
get the Athenians to do
what he wanted to do whether
in fact they liked it to begin with
or not. He persuaded them to do it.
So I don't think that was really a flaw.
The problem was that things
went wrong almost immediately.
And then such terrible
things were happening as did
shake his power for a while.
But even then he came back into power
and still the strategy wasn't working.
I think the problem therefore I think
you could say he knew what he was doing.
He thought he could get away with it and
he could have if the strategy had been
correct.
You know to start with you.
Uh uh uh.
People from the different
Oh yes.
Yes.
The question is
ancient writers Plutarch is whom
you're really talking about.
They give Pericles credit for being a
great general but they say bad things
about Nicholas who was involved
in the great defeat in Sicily.
And yet
Nicholas pursued something like the
strategy of Pericles which was avoiding
these conflicts.
Well I think
first thing I want to point out
is that subsidies didn't do that.
Not only this facilities so thoroughly
support the strategy of Pericles he
writes and in incoming him on the death
of Nicholas that raises him to the level
of Pericles or higher
in his own estimation.
But in the case of Nicholas it was in
a way even worse than what Pericles did
because Nicholas first of all was against
the war against going to Sicily in the
first place.
Then when he was chosen
to be general he went.
But before he did that he tried to
convince the having lost the vote shall we
go.
He then decided to trick the Athenians
into not going any way by saying to them
oh well if you're going to go all right
but it'll be perfectly safe if you just
sort of take this.
The original fleet was going
to have 60 ships period.
Well it ended up having
130 ships 5000 hop lights
raising the risk of that thing to the
level that finally made it seem like they
could lose the war by losing the
Sicilian campaign. And he didn't.
The Athenians instead of saying
which what he expected. Oh no no.
If that's what we have to do let's not go.
Instead they said Right on.
Yes you can have everything you ask
for Nick is what would you like.
And off they went.
And thereafter his performance on that
expedition is one of somebody who doesn't
really want to carry out his instructions.
He just what he would have liked to
do was having lost the argument twice.
Now he went out and did everything he
could to avoid confronting any battle in
Syracuse and was finally driven to fight
at Syracuse very much against his will.
And then I could you know go back and
read it but he screws up the detail of it
over and over again.
And so I think there are good grounds
for condemning him as a general whereas
the grounds on which Pericles should be
criticized I think is as a strategist
rather than as a commander
anybody else.
Yeah.
No.
But I think they.
Well I'll make one little exception to
that but I I think they could have had a
very good chance to come out of the war
in the way Pericles hoped they would if
they had pursued the limited aggressive
program that was undertaken by Clinton
in Damascus and these after
the death of Pericles.
So taking pilots building afforded pylons
taking Cicero building a fourth there
and perhaps even a few other places on
the periphery of the Peloponnese and
launching attacks from those places but
not staying to fight the Spartans at any
great battle just causing that to happen
if they had been able to do that for a
stretch of time then the hope that Clay
on had that the headlights might escape
to these forts and that then ultimately
bring about an internal upheaval which
the Spartans panic might happen would have
led the Spartans to offer peace and in
fact they do the Spartans off peace many
many. You could argue that
if the Athenians had simply
accepted the Spartan peace
offer in for twenty five the war would
have been over and the Athenian Empire
would've been intact just
the way Pericles wanted it.
So not only could they have done it they
would have done it if they'd accepted
it. They wouldn't accept victory you
could argue as many a scholar does.
You have the only other point I want
to make is after that didn't happen and
finally a peace was drawn up and signed
then in effect in 421 which is another
evidence that they could achieve what
they wanted by the techniques that were
put forward.
But after that happened that peace
broke down and now the Athenians found
themselves part of a new alliance of
states Peloponnese as Athenians with three
Peloponnesian democracies who produce
a big land battle in the Peloponnese.
And the Athenians come that I mean the
enemies of Sparta come that close to
defeating the Spartan army
in the Peloponnesian War.
Had they done that they would
have finished Sparta off
as a dominant power grid.
So the answer is they they actually had
it in their hands a couple of times and
in another time they missed by about an
inch. Yeah. They could've won that way.
I think we're out of time. Let me wish
you all a very happy holiday. Bye bye.